That his brother and went to feed their
father's flock and check him.
So they took off and Israel said unto
Joseph,
do you know what my brother and feed the
flock and check him calm and I will send
thee unto him.
And he said to him and he said to him
here,
here tomorrow.
And when they saw him afar off,
even before he came near onto them,
they conspired against him to slay him.
Rough people back then,
right?
This is,
this sort of thing is happening quite
frequently.
And they said to one another,
behold the dreamer cometh.
Come now therefore let us slay him,
cast him into some pit and we will say
some evil beast has devoured him and we
shall see what becomes of his dreams.
So there's an echo of the Cain and Abel
story there.
Obviously,
you know what I mean?
It's not quite as clear because indicate
enables store able is clearly just doing
well.
And here you can't quite get a handle on
Joseph's character.
You can't tell if he is actually the
elect or if he's just a spoiled Brat
with delusions of grandeur,
you know?
And,
but it doesn't matter because his
brothers,
they're so irritated at his,
the fact that he's favored and perhaps
even the fact that he might be someone
destined for for something special,
that they find it perfectly reasonable
to destroy that and it's so hard.
It's so interesting how often that motif
of pulling down in ideal manifest itself
in these old stories,
right?
It's,
it's the pattern is established in the
Cain and Abel Story.
It just repeats and repeats and repeats
and I think that's dead true.
I think it just repeats all the time so
that people are annoyed about how tragic
their lives are.
They're annoyed that they're subject to
malevolence and they're annoyed that
they're not doing as well as other
people are doing and that makes them up,
puts them exactly into this state of
mind.
Now,
maybe with modern people,
if you're going to kill someone because
you're resentful as a modern person,
you don't generally slay them and throw
them into a pit.
You know what you do is you just killed
them slowly over a few decades and it
isn't obvious to me that that's any
better.
So I've seen plenty of married couples
who were in that situation.
It's like,
it's like there is this Mitch Hedberg,
he used to complain about turtleneck
phase.
It was like being strangled by a really
weak midget and it's probably really
politically incorrect joke,
but it's a funny joke.
So,
uh,
and then you see,
you see relationships that are like
that.
It's like each person has their hands
around the neck of the other person,
but they don't have enough courage to
actually to squeeze it,
just put enough pressure on to cut the
circulation off a tiny bit.
So the person just gets like a die over
a 30 year period,
something like that.
So yeah,
and you all laugh because you know,
it's true.
That's why it's.